- [Wenhu] Maybe we can get started.
Hello everyone, my name's Wenhu Chen.
So I'm currently an Assistant Professor
at University of Waterloo.
So I'm also a faculty member
at Vector Institute and CIFAR AI chair.
So today I'm going to talk about
deep learning for NLP, right?
So this is a very broad topic.
I'm teaching this whole
course at the university.
But now I only have like
an hour to talk about it.
So I do a lot of compression
and I'm trying to only highlight
some of the key milestones
in the history of NLP.
And some of the materials
will be too fundamentals,
so just bear with me.
To accommodate everyone's need, you know?
And so the content we're
going to cover today,
it's not moving, right?
Yeah, so the content we're going to cover
consists of like the five parts.
So the first one is recurrent neural net.
So basically I'll talk about what is RNN,
what is LSTM, and then I'll talk about
what is the tension mechanism,
basically like how do you use
the tension mechanism to do
all sorts of application,
like machine translation,
image captioning, and so on and so forth.
And then we're going to
talk about transformers.
Which is totally built upon
the attention mechanism.
And then once we have the transformers,
we have like different types
of self supervised learning,
pre-training or so on and so forth,
like T5, Redbird or whatsoever,
I'll cover some of this.
And then finally, I'll talk about
like right now, I guess
the most popular topic,
large language model.
And I'll try to talk about
in context to learning,
prompting and scaling
law, this kind of stuff.
Yeah, so if you have any question,
you can raise your hand and let me see
if I can make some
clarification on my end.
- [Moderator] Sorry, just
a very quick comment.
If you have questions, please use the mic
so that your voice can
be recorded, thanks.
- [Wenhu] Yeah, let's
review some of the basics.
So neural net, I guess
all of you already know
like how neural nets are working.
So neural nets consists
of like a lot of neurons,
and also synapsis.
Basically the weights
connecting different neurons,
these are the learnable parameters.
We're going to optimize these parameters
to make this neural net
to accomplish any task that we desire.
So in computer vision,
there is convolutional neural net,
which basically takes images as the input
and then try to run some
small convolutional kernels
to extract localized
features from the image,
and then do some downstream task.
Like detections, image classifications,
and so on and so forth.
And so in NLP, we normally,
we talk about a lot of tasks
like machine translation, summarization,
image captioning, so on and so forth.
A lot of this NLP task can
be unified into one format
which is basically a sequence
of items as the input,
and then a sequence of
items as the output.
So the items could be a lot of things.
This items in the sequence
could be like words,
letters, image features
and so on and so forth.
That's why like a predominant,
like a view of NLP is basically called
sequence-to-sequence modeling.
So I'm not sure if you can see the video.
Yeah, it's running well.
And so sequence-to-sequence model
basically takes a sequence,
like item by item as the
input and try to output
a lot of items like also token by token.
And then the sequence-to-sequence model.
So one of the most popular architecture
is called encoder and decoder model.
So it basically, the encoder
will compile the information
it receives into a vector.
And then after processing
this information,
this vector will be sent to the decoder,
and then the decoder will
start generating things.
Like tokens or paragraphs or anything.
So this is also like
kind of a visualization,
so this is a machine translation task.
You can think of it as a
sequence-to-sequence modeling.
So on the left hand side
you have like maybe some French words,
you kind of tokenize them
into individual tokens
and then you'll feed this
tokens one by one to an encoder,
and then the encoder try
to comprehend the meeting
and then compress all the
information right into a vector.
And then this vector will be
passed to the decoder model
to start generating maybe
like the translation
of the French sentence,
something like that.
So how does it work?
So how does the encoder actually work?
What's the underlying mechanism?
So the very basic one is
called recurrent neural net.
Recurrent neural net,
which is basically a
recurrent computation machine.
So you can think of it as
like several components
here you have the input,
which is X, where you have also a state,
this is the most important part.
So the state will receive input of X
and then try to update its belief
about what it has perceived so far,
and then it tries to
generate some output as all.
And so this recurrence can be
unfolded from left to right
into this kind of mechanism.
So it's basically some sort
of multi-layer perception,
but it's kind of enrolled in
to include the time dimension as well.
And a lot of this weights are shared
across different timestamp.
So this is a recurrent recursion formula,
which is pretty simple, right?
You take the input and then
multiply with the matrix,
and then the previous state also multiply
with the transition matrix,
and then you kind of update
the state from ST-1 to ST.
And then you output the,
like the output state of OT
by multiply another matrix over ST.
So this is the most basic
recurrent neural network.
And then one of the drawback
of this simple design
is that it's totally linear, right?
I'd say it's not able to capture
a lot of this very complex behavior
in our natural language
or any other sequence to sequence task.
That's why people propose like different,
more advanced recurrent neural nets.
Like one example is this long
short-term memory network,
and there are also some other variants
like AGIU or something like that.
So basically in this type of model,
so it includes more like
non-linearity basically,
there are some activation function,
basically it's composed of
like sigmoid or hypertension
that kind of function so that the model
or the architecture can be more expressive
in terms of modeling
different types of behavior.
And the key findings of
this architecture is that
it has three different mechanism.
One is the forget gate,
the other is the input gate.
And finally they have like a output gate,
which is basically the FT for gap gate,
I is the input gate and O, right?
So we can see there's
a lot of stuff going on
in this one transition function.
So let's break this down
into several different part.
And for example, if we want
to comprehend the sentence,
Bob is a nice person
and then on the other hand is evil, right?
So at the sentence break,
when you start a new sentence,
we do want to forget about
like Bob or whatsoever
and then start a new sentence, right?
So that's why the LSTM
introduced this mechanism
of forgetting gate, right?
So at some step,
so the model tries to predict
like a number between zero and one,
which means that how
much memory should I keep
from the last stage?
If this is like a new sentence,
probably I just throw
away all the memories
about like the previous context
and start from beginning.
If I'm in the middle of the sentence
I should probably have like a higher value
of like retaining the past context.
So the forgetting will
be kind of disabled.
So this is one gate,
the other gate is the input gate.
So the input gate controls
how much information flows
from the input of X.
So for example, in the same sentence,
if you talk about Bob here and Bob there
so there are some new
contexts describing Bob.
You want to have this new information
being kind of merged or fused
into the original like context vector.
And this is called like in the input gate.
And once you have like the
input and the forget gate,
and then you have the context.
So from this context,
this context is presumably multifaceted
because it captures like a
lot of aspects about Bob.
But like right here, if we
want to generate the next word,
so it's reflecting a
certain aspect of Bob.
So that's why we need some to choose
or select some aspect out of
the hidden states that we have,
and that's why we have the output gate.
So the output gate will be like more like
a selective module trying to only select
the most relevant information
out of the context.
So these are like the three
big modules inside the LSTM
to capture different sorts of behaviors.
Because in your sentence
or in your paragraph
sometimes you need to forget,
and you need to start from scratch,
and sometimes you need
to digest the information
and sometimes you need to select
which information to output.
So this is the underlying
mechanism of LSTM.
So for LSTM it can be also
used for machine translation.
So the basic idea is that
for a lot of these words,
we can use word embedding
and each word can be
represented as a vector.
So these vectors will be
basically the X from here,
and you have this X
and then you run through
the LSTM mechanism
that I talked about.
Try to process this X
one by one and try to get
the context vector of this LSTM.
And then you have this context fracture,
and then you have another LSTM,
which is the decoder that tries to
condition on the context
and trying to output
the words token by token.
It's basically, there are a
lot of optimizable parameters
both of this LSTM, so you can optimize it
to generate the things that you want.
Try to kind of twist it
to do the things that you want basically.
So here, like this is an example of
a neuro machine
translation using our LSTM.
So you fit this word by word,
and then you use the last
hidden stage of the LSTM,
and then you fit it into the decoder,
and then the decoder will
also go through this LSTM
and try to generate a token by token.
And then we're going to move
on to the attention mechanism.
So one of the problem
of the previous approach
is that we only, and
there are two problems.
One is that we are basically processing
the input like token by token.
For example, if there are two tokens,
that I position and J position,
you literally need to run the
model, like J minus I steps,
to let these two tokens
interact with each other.
So this is very common
in natural language.
We have a lot of co reference.
This course structure,
we keep referring to things
that we talked about.
But sometimes these words
can be separated far apart.
And so these kind of like
token by token architecture
cannot capture this kind of
long dependency very well.
And secondly, as you can
see in the last video,
so the model basically
compress all the information
from the encoder side into one vector.
Sometimes this vector,
you know, this vector
is a fixed size vector.
For example, you feel like
have like a whole paragraph.
It's impossible to compress
all of them into just one vector.
Yeah. So how can we make
this model more flexible.
Is there an easy fix?
So in this part I'll mainly talk about
how we address the second issue.
How to make the context
vector more flexible.
Which is easy, basically
previously we only passed
one vector from the
encoder to the decoder.
So maybe we can just fit all the vectors
from the encoder to the decoder
This is a very easy fix, right?
So you goes through the encoder RNN
and you get first hidden
state, and then the second,
and then the third you
just compile them together
and then feed all of them to the decoder,
and then the decoder will be able to,
like be able to figure out what to grab
from the encoder side instead
of like the encoder to decide
what should I compress, right?
So that's what we call
as attention mechanism
like from the decoder side.
So the attention decoder
doesn't actually stop
before producing output.
It basically looks at the
set of encoder hidden states.
So each encoder hidden
state is mostly associated
with certain words because it's produced
like token by token.
And we're going to...
So the decoder will give each
of the hidden state a score,
basically like how relevant
this state is with respect to
the one things that I want to output.
And then we're going to
multiply each hidden state
by its soft max score and thus amplifying
the hidden state that are
relevant to my output,
and then throwing away the hidden states
that are irrelevant to
what I want to pursue.
So in order to better understand this,
you can see this video.
So basically you have,
let's say here you have
some encoded hidden state
like H1, H2, H3, you know,
for example, this is a
very simple visualization.
Let's say we only have three words.
And then we want to
decode the hidden state
for the times step four.
And then now we kind of
attend to all of this
encoder hidden state, and then we got to,
we get their score, right?
So basically how relevant they are.
But this is not normalized.
We can use some soft max
like a normalization to
get a distribution of this.
And then you're going to
multiply the softmax score
with all this hidden state
and then aggregate them
into one vector, right?
So this vector will represent
what I need from the encoder output.
So this is pretty dynamic
and it's doing very
well in a lot of cases.
So the attention flow,
like more formally can
be expressed as this,
so the RNN processes input
producing an output,
and then a new hidden state vector, H4.
And so because now it's at
the fourth stack, right?
So in the attention step,
we're going to use the
encoder hidden states
and the H4 vector to calculate
the context of vector
for this step, basically using
the mechanism of weighted sum
that I just mentioned,
and then we concatenate
H4 and C4 into one vector,
and this vector will be fed into
another feedforward neural network.
And this neural network will
decide which word to output.
So this is basically the
fourth step computation.
We can repeat this for
any number of times.
So here is another video of
teaching you how to do this.
So here we are at the fourth step,
because we already have like
three encoder hidden state
and we are generating the fourth one.
So we will fit like the start token here,
and then we will have like the H4
it's like some initialized vector.
And then I will use this to
query all these hidden states.
So there are one, two,
three, four of them,
and then you calculate the softmax score
and then you do the weighted sum,
and then you get this
hidden stage, which is C4.
And then you concatenate
C4 and H4 together
and then put that into a
feedforward neural network
and then it will generate the work.
Hopefully this is I, right?
And then on this I will be like,
this embedding will
fit into the step five.
And then you just go through
like the whole thing again.
And then it'll attend to, you know,
all this in hidden state,
encoded hidden states again.
Now it's attending to a different thing
because when you are
translating your position moves,
you attend to different context
depending on the position of your decoder,
and then you fit it to maybe like a,
to get C5 feedforward neural network,
and then you generate
the output of M, right?
So on and so forth.
You can run this until
like end of sentence token or whatsoever.
And one thing that we observe is that
if you plot out the attention map,
like attention map basically
is like the softmax score.
So let's say this is
like the decoder side,
and this is the encoder side.
So when I'm translating the first word,
it lays a lot of attention on this word,
like this French word.
When I'm translating this,
the attention kind of highlights on this,
so on and so forth.
You can see there's like the overarching
like diagonal trend.
So if you know French and English
you can see that these token
from English and French,
they're aligned very well.
So which also enhances the
interpretability of the model.
And even more we could generalize
this attention based LSTM
to do image captioning as well.
So what we're going to do is
that instead of like using RNNs
to process word as the input,
we can use CNNs to process
image as the input.
Now we have like the CNN going to give us
like a feature map, right?
So you can flatten this
feature map just like the RNN,
so you will have a lot
of localized features
extracted from the input image,
and then you use the LSTM
with some attention mechanism
and then try to generate
the caption word by word.
And as you can see, some of the people,
I think this was
published at Mila in 2015,
this is a very, a highly cited paper.
So if you are going to
visualize the attention,
so we can see like
when the captioning
model is generating bird,
it tries to attend to
bird most of the time.
When it's generating like
something like water or something,
it blocks out the bird
will attend more to the surrounding water
or something like that.
So this is very fancy at that time
people have never seen
such kind of mechanism.
So that's why it arouses a lot of interest
in pursuing this type of, you know,
interpretable generative model.
And then that's why we
have the transformer model.
So I already talked about
like how to kind of break the,
let me see what's the time?
So it's 1:00, it's already 1:00.
Yeah, it's to 2:30, right?
Okay, sounds good.
We already talk about how
we break the bottleneck
of the contact vector,
so we haven't touched on
upon the other weakness,
which is how can we capture
the long-term dependency
between tokens that are
further apart in the input,
and how can we make it more flexible?
If you look at the recurrent
neural network architecture,
if you unroll it from left to right,
you can see that something
like this, right?
And the encoder, so the RNNs
and tries to use the injective buyers that
like all the sequences,
a lot of the contacts are local, right?
They try to process things locally,
which is a good heuristic,
but it also has some bottleneck.
For example, the RNNs going to take
the order of sequence length time
to make the distant word
interact with each other, right?
So for example, if you are
processing this sentence
the chef who blah, blah,
blah, blah and worse.
And then this worse and chef, they are
they're highly connected, right?
But there might be, you know,
I mean a hundred tokens in between.
So the model already forget
what's going on with the chef,
you know, maybe mis remembers
that it's not a chef,
it's maybe a doctor or maybe a policeman
or something like that.
So this could cause a lot of issues
when we're doing NLP, right?
So with this like kind
of linearized recurrence,
it's very hard for us to learn
the long distance dependency.
And this is mainly because
the gradient propagation issue
because it's using the BPTT algorithm
and you basically need
to propagate the gradient
by many steps from here to here
to actually learn the
long-term dependency.
So this learning paradigm
basically prevents the model
from like getting, capturing
this long-term dependency.
And so this is not the
best way to do an NLP.
So that's why like I think
in 2017 or something,
so Google has published this paper called
Attention Is All you Need and basically
proposed that we don't even
need the recurrent architecture,
we can just use attention
for the whole network.
The whole network is just
built upon attention mechanism.
How can we do that, right?
So we going to use like the...
Attention going to treat each
word's representation as a query,
and then trying to access
and incorporate information
from the entire sequence, right?
So there is no recurrence at all here.
And one good thing about
this is it can be done
in a very highly parallelized way.
Because in GPU it has a lot of this
parallelized computation unit.
If you use transformer,
it can best exploit
the parallelism residing inside the GPU.
So right now, because there
is no kind of recurrence,
the maximum interaction
distance or the complexity
for two tokens to interact with each other
suddenly drop to constant
or one basically,
and all the words will interact
with each other at all level.
So for example, here in the second layer,
so this hidden stage
going to interact with
all the input word embedding.
And then you're going to
do this self attention
over this whole layer.
And then you're going to stack
another self attention layer
on top of that, and then you on this layer
you can also kind of interact
with all the hidden states
from the last layer, so on and so forth.
You can stack this maybe a hundred layers
to capture all sorts of very
sophisticated interactions
between different words
and so on and so forth.
So attention can be seen as a
performing a very fuzzy lookup
in a key value store.
So in a lookup table, we have
a table of key and values.
Basically if here we are having a word,
lets query, and then we try to grab
the most relevant words out of this
inventory of key and value pairs,
and then we're going to do the output.
But if you're going to design it this way,
like some hard selection,
this is not differentiable.
So that's why they do like
a more softer version of like lookout.
So this is also based on
the attention mechanism
that I already talked about.
You just compute like the score
with respect to each of the key value pair
and do a softmax over all of them,
and then do the weighted sum
to calculate all of them.
But in this case, most
of the time the softmax
try to polarize the attention weights.
And then if you look at the attention,
it's mostly specified.
And then the model is
only kind of attending to
several individual key value pairs.
So this is like the transformer encoder,
which consists of two part.
One is the self attention
layer that I talked about
where like the model
kind of attend to itself
and then it's all of this nearby
tokens within the sequence.
And then after that we
will have like another
feetforward neural network trying to add
more express like power into it,
like adding more non-linearity here,
so on and so forth, right?
So here, if we have only have two words
we can help design like
the self attention layer
and then it'll let this two
tokens interact with each other
to get the representation of Z1, Z2.
And then you're going to put that through
like a feetforward neural network
to calculate the real
output of this single block.
And then you can do this
like layer by layer.
So for example, if you
have N encoder layers,
you're going to repeat this process
until you finally reach the last layer.
So here is basically representing,
like repeating what I said.
Basically if you have two words,
you're going to project the
word embedding into three,
the three different vectors,
one's the query vector,
one's a key vector and one
is the value vector, right?
And then you're going
to use the query and key
to calculate one score.
So this is basically dark product
and then you can see you have
like this two dark product
and then you normalize
it into the softmax,
and then you combine them
with the weighted sum
and then you will get Z one.
So basically the think will
find it after the self attention
will also generate like one vector.
And similarly for machine,
you will do the same thing
and then you will generate another vector.
And like in a nutshell,
this can be expressed in
a matrix format like this.
And like another very smart design
in this transformer is that
it not only has one attention,
it has multiple attention,
parallel attention,
which we call multi-head, right?
Multi-head attention it
increases the model's capacity
to attempt differently.
So basically like in this word,
it probably like in this
aspect, it tend to this word.
Maybe it's trying to express something,
attend to some other words.
So there are different,
like this could increase
the model's capacity
to leverage different
attention from the input.
And what it does is basically
you have like this multi
attention output, right?
You just concatenate all of them together
and then you go through
another projection layer
to finally combine them all
this multi-head into one output.
And yeah, so there are some
layer normalization after this.
I'll just fast forward this part
and then you can stack a lot
of this self attention layers
on top of each other.
And on the decoder part,
it's also self attention.
But there is another caveat.
It's not only attending to itself,
but it's also attending to
the encoder output, right?
So here you're going to
switch out how you calculate
the key and value on pairs.
It's not coming from itself,
it's basically coming from the ones
that you already
calculated by the encoder.
And then we're going to talk
about self supervised learning.
So transformer is basically
the most important
architecture right now.
So a lot of the work has been
done on top of transformers.
And so here we've just
assumed that we have
like a transformer model.
So like one of the key like task
in natural language processing,
it's called language model.
Language modeling is
basically trying to predict
the next word given the
past context, right?
And so like, and actually
in order to learn this,
you don't actually need any annotation
or any supervised data
because it's basically
just you grab some contacts
from the web, right?
And then you can have some past contacts
and to predict the next
token and so on and so forth.
This is what we call a
self supervision, right?
So it's not supervised by any human
or anything or more explicitly.
So, and it's trying to get
the signal from the web.
And try to infuse this
into the neural parameters.
And then once we train this model
to perform this language modeling,
we can save this pre-trained
model as the checkpoint.
And then once we do some downstream tasks,
we're going to initialize our weights
from the save the
checkpoint so that we could
do the optimization more efficiently.
So for the self supervised learning,
there were a lot of stuff
going on at that time.
I think I remember it in
like 2018, 2019 or 2020.
There are different studies
trying to investigate
what is the best self
supervised objective.
So like the OpenAI trust
is next token prediction.
They have been always
doing this even in GPT-3.
So the basic idea is very simple.
You have a sentence you
found from like the web,
and then you mask the next
word like mask some word
and then use the past window,
the previous window and
then try to predict that,
that's called next token prediction.
And then also some other work like BERT
who tries to explore other alternative
where you have like a whole sentence
and then you mask one of the token, right?
And then you try to predict this word,
not only from the left hand side,
but also from the right hand side.
And there are also other
objective for example,
if you have a complete sentence
and then you have another,
some other sentence you're
going to predict which one
is the sentence that
follows this sentence.
Or there are also other
sentence reordering task
where you kind of perturb all
the words inside the sentence
and then you try to reconstruct
the original ordering.
So there are tons of papers
in investigating this
like GPT-2, BERT, RoBERTa, Ernie, T5,
Albert, Bart, UL2, so on and so forth.
There are plenty of them.
And so some of them are using like
decoder only architecture where basically
like the whole architecture
just a decoder.
There's no encoder at all.
Some examples are like GPT-2, GPT-3,
LaMDA and there are some
only using the encoder
and there's no decoder like BERT
and some other variants
like RoBERTa whatsoever.
And there's also like
encoder decoder architecture
like transformers, T5,
BERT, so on and so forth.
And so now like with all this
super self supervised learning,
so the community shifted
to another paradigm
where, well, whatever we do,
we first try to pre-train the model
on some self supervised tasks
and then we fine tune on our end task
like machine translation
dialogue, anything, right?
So this has bumped the score up by a lot.
So if you look at like the
fine tune transformer model,
so like for example, like the GPT-2,
it's able to achieve so high performance
on a lot of the benchmarks.
Like here, these are like some,
I think it's natural
language inference task
and then also some reading
comprehension task.
So people have observed
that with this pre-training,
the end model performance can jump a lot
in a lot of the cases.
And then finally we're going to talk about
a large language model.
So large language model
has been very popular.
So this is before GPT-3.
As you can see, ELMo is also
like a pre-training master,
which was proposed in 2017,
which only uses 94 million parameters.
And then we have like GPT, BERT,
transformer ELMo, GPT-2,
so on and so forth.
Most of them are only
residing in the regime
of like several hundreds
of millions of parameters
except the Nvidia one,
which is the megaelectron-LM,
which has 8 billion parameters.
And then GPT-3 come out, right?
You can see that all these models
they compare so small,
like with respect to GPT-3.
GPT-3 just increases from
like hundreds of million
to hundreds of billion.
You know, it's a thousand times larger
than all the other models.
So it's crazy.
Like one of the key
observation from OpenAI is that
it's called scaling law.
Scaling law means that if you train
this large language model,
and then you observe
it's final like converged test loss,
test loss is basically a perplexity.
It's basically telling
you how perplexed you are
in terms of generating the next token
on a validation coppers
or something like that.
So presumably the lower tasks loss
means that the model is better.
It correlates very well
with the downstream task.
And as you can see,
so this is basically a linear line.
It means that the OpenAI found that
the more compute you throw in,
the better model you can get.
And then it also scales log-linearly.
If you use the empirical results
and then you try to fit
it, it's almost one line.
It's almost a line, right?
So with this, you can almost
deterministically predict
how well your model is
biospecific compute.
And it's also logged linearly
with respect to the token,
the dataset size that you are training at,
like basically how many tokens
you have in your dataset.
So here, there are scales
from like a few million to,
I think this is like a billion, right?
So right now the models
that we are training
are using like hundreds
of billions of tokens.
And then it's also lot-linearly scales
with the parameter size of the model.
And you can see that GPT-3
tries to investigate it.
What would be the outcome if
we train a lot of these models.
From like small, medium, large excel,
so on and so forth into 175 billion,
which is GPT-3 right?
So we can see that all these models,
they fit this like their lowest point
in the converging test validation loss,
it fits this line very well.
This is a huge discovery.
It basically give us a guide of how well
I can actually get with when I throw in
this amount of computer
or something like that.
And then with these models now,
like open AI found like a
new way to use this model.
Basically, you don't need to
kind of fine tune it at all.
You just prompt it
and then it will generate
things that you want.
So there are different
prompting methodology,
there's no prompt one,
which means that there's no
natural language instruction.
You just give it some examples.
Like there are zero
shot, one shot few shots.
And then there's ones with
natural language instruction,
basically telling the
model what you are doing
and also giving you some
sort of demonstration
about how this task is being solved.
And then the in-context
learning, you know,
basically when you are doing
gradient descent over the model,
it implicitly learns how to
do the in-context learning.
And so what this model like,
and so here are some
of the examples, right?
So you basically having
some sort of demonstration,
then the model kind of imitate
the behavior very well.
And so the in-content learning
is defined as following.
So the model develops a
pattern recognition abilities
while training, which can be
applied to inference time.
So the capability is emergent
as the model scales up.
Which means that when the model is small,
like the model can't do this
in contextual anywhere well.
But if you scale it up to like
a hundred billion parameters,
it suddenly learns how to do it
and do it very well basically.
And so, however, if you look into
the unsupervised learning objective,
there's no explicit
guidance to teach the model
how to do in-context learning,
how to imitate a few demonstration
and then do the like same
thing on the unseen input.
But there are a lot of
active ongoing research
trying to investigate why, how
this kind of behavior emerge.
And so these are some of the like results
provided by OpenAI.
So during the training
uses some very exact task
like remove a random symbol from a word.
As you can see,
by increasing the demonstration examples,
the model tries to like
gets much and much better
performance and as you can see,
the larger the model gets
the performance it will
increase dramatically
from like 20% to 60%, something like that.
And one thing that we also observe is that
when you have enough examples,
you don't even need the
natural language instruction.
You just give it some like examples.
The model can already
reach the same performance
with the counterpart with
natural language instruction.
(audience member speaking faintly)
Could you repeat the question?
Oh yeah, I'm sorry.
So you were saying that,
how does the model evaluate this, right?
Measure? So they basically
use a synthetic task.
So basically requires the
model to remove a random symbol
from an input sequence like A, B, C, D.
Tries to remove any
maybe C or D or anything
and then generate like the output.
So this is a very easy
task just trying to do
some diagnostic about like whether model
can learn this very simple skill.
The parameters, learnable
parameters from the model.
Yeah. So there are like
1.6, 1.3 billion parameter,
13 billion parameter and
175 billion parameters.
As you can see, you know,
as you scale up the model,
the performance going to
jump very significantly.
And so that's like some
synthetic test, right?
Let's look at some more
realistic task called TriviaQA.
So this comprises of a lot of questions
from this TriviaQA test
and it's asking about
like some random knowledge
in our daily life, right?
So you can see that as
the model scales up,
the performance can
improve very significantly,
like from maybe like 10 to 30 to 50 until
like 70 or something.
And what surprises us is that
the model hasn't converged yet.
It's kind of in like
improving linearly right now.
So which means that if you scale the model
to like a trillion parameter or something,
maybe you can already get
a hundred percent accuracy.
So this is very intriguing.
Basically you give the model
like some sort of examples
to imitate basically.
Yeah. That's why like the
improvement is not very dramatic
Just a few percentage
of if you look at that.
So it's only like a few percentage.
But you at least need like one example
to actually teach the model
what is the format of the
answer something like that.
But giving it, you know,
like 64, 63 more, you know,
you only get a very small jump
like maybe seven or 5%
something like that.
And then the GPT-3 if you
are going to evaluate it
on some of the major NLP
task like machine translation
and whatsoever like reading comprehension.
Without training the model at all,
you just give it like a few shot example
and then do prompting,
the model is already getting
a very good performance
on a lot of these tasks,
and these results are coming from 2020.
So these are pretty old right now
I assume that with GPT-4
you already get like
much, much higher performance.
So why is in-context
learning so good, right?
Why does people love
in-context learning so much?
I guess one reason being
that the previous master
still requires the model
you to fine tune the model.
But fine tuning is very expensive.
The expense comes from two sides.
One is that if you want
to do gradient descent,
you need a lot of GPUs, right?
GPU memory whatsoever.
And then you also need to,
after fine tuning the model,
you need to save the
checkpoint in your disk.
Like each of the checkpoint
could be, you know,
like tens of gigabytes which
is very expensive to save.
But now with in-context learning,
you don't need to do any
gradient design at all.
You just give it some prompt
and then it does everything for you.
And then one single model
can solve all the tasks
without any adaptation.
The adaptation is only on the input,
so what kind of input you try to give it,
what kind of demonstration you give it.
That's why problem engineering becomes
like a very popular fashion right now.
And yeah, so with that I
want to conclude this talk.